i'm holding coffee in my hand so we're
going to use this for a very quick demo
right at the start so let's see if i
just do this i'm going to take a handful
of coffee granules
drop them
and we get a pattern that looks like
that let me get rid of the rest of them
question is
is that random what do you think bertie
well
i guess there are sort of factors like
the breeze in the room and the starting
conditions and we could even ask you
know do the the coffee grains stick
together somehow does that cause them to
cluster is that you know giving rise to
some of the partnering but the
interesting thing is we can eyeball it
and often you know physicists are as bad
as many other people and they'll eyeball
a pattern and go yeah it looks pretty
random to me but actually how do you
work out if it's random and what do i
mean by random what i mean are the
points uncorrelated is there no
relationship between the positions of
the grains are they entirely unrelated
there's one thing that connects all
scientists regardless of the discipline
physicist chemist biologist it's that we
look for patterns that's you know either
in data in time or in space and we try
to look for correlations we try to look
for relationships
but the problem is
we can be as easily fooled as everybody
else despite all our training and
despite all our supposed mathematical
thinking often you ask us simple
questions
and here's a good example we've got two
arrangements of dots on uh on a plane on
a piece of paper so from this wonderful
book by a guy called steven j gold bully
for brontosaurus it's page 266.
which one's random brady which one's
entirely random
so i've been asking a lot of people that
very same question brady and the vast
majority physicists are not physicists
will go this is the random one and you
ask them why and you say well actually
in this one i can see sort of clusters
and groups and chains and sort of
correlations that you know you wouldn't
expect if it was random
turns out this is the random one so the
interesting thing with this is that
there are no spatial correlations here
these points are independent and that
clustering you see is the natural
outcome of something called pros-on
statistics so cross-on statistics mean
that you've got no relationship no
correlation between those points they're
completely independent of each other in
this case what's actually which looks to
many people looks more random you don't
see the clustering it's not like you can
pull out
linear chains or clusters or even
constellations if you think about the
stars with this one what's happened is
that instead of putting the points down
completely at random what your computer
does here you put the comp you choose
the points at random but you only fill
in the box as it were you only fill in
the dot if the surrounding neighborhood
is free of other points so what we see
here is that there was a natural
correlation a natural spatial
relationship between the points here
that isn't there often you know
particularly just in our favorite paper
last week brady there was another
instance of a story based on seeing the
face of jesus but the face of jesus has
been seen in
you know tea leaves and coffee stains
and
paints and taps and various many other
weird and wacky and wonderful
locations and we scoff at that
and we say well you know of course this
is just random but again it's a question
of what do we mean when we say something
is random and how do we detect
and the way the first thing that
physicists turn to which is sometimes
not always the best way but certainly
it's the way i love is something called
furry analysis and furry analysis is a
remarkable method of basically
decomposing images down into the
component parts and looking looking at
them it's like sort of almost particle
physicist physics for images where
you're breaking it down into its
component parts and looking at the
relationship between those various
components and how they build up an
image the very interesting thing is that
you can decompose these images any image
not just these image any image anything
on the internet can be decomposed down
into a sum of very simple um sort of
like the algebra of images very simple
sine waves and so we can i've got a few
examples on screen so what we have here
is a very simple image of a wave where
what we have here is bright dark bright
but as you can see it's a gradation so
what you have is bright intensity here
going down to darken and coming up if we
were to draw a line through this and
look at how that intensity varies what
you'd get
is a sine wave so this is effectively a
two two dimensional sine wave
okay okay so that's our basic unit
and what we can do is we can stretch
that wave we can increase the frequency
of that wave so we can
change the number
that's a terrible wave but you get the
idea we can change that the frequency
and the wavelength of that wave we can
change the number of waves in a given
you know unit of length and that's
actually something called a spatial
frequency so what we can do is we take
this sine wave and we take this sine
wave
so this is a very
arbitrary way of adding them together
but you'll see that as i add them and as
i change the orientation of one with
respect to the other because this one is
now transparent as i move it
it is it looks pretty cool it looks
quite psychedelic but you know it's
that's sort of what you'd expect not the
mona lisa
it's not the mona lisa but
what's
remarkable is that as i said you can
break any image down
into those type of waves and physicists
do this all the time astronomers do this
all the time in terms of the for example
the cosmic microwave background how do
you analyze that you see blobs
how are you actually going to pull
information out of that and we spend our
life looking at images around us we need
to quantify those images it's okay to
eyeball something and say well there's a
pattern there but how do you actually
know there's a partner where we've seen
that you know you can have clusters
forming very easily just purely from a
random process what we're going to do
here we're going to build up an image
right so that's actually four
components four different waves added
together just with different
orientations perhaps different
frequencies different amplitudes
boring
what we're going to do now is just add
more and more waves together maybe nine
still looks fairly boring that's nine
waves that's nine waves so let's go to
64.
starting to see something coming out
remember all we're doing is taking those
breaking that image down into separate
waves and adding them up that's all
we're doing nothing more sophisticated
than that and let's say we go to let's
go to 100 this time
does it start to become a little bit
recognizable maybe i'll add some more
components in but i hope you can see the
ripples the waves and it's not just this
i'm stressed it's not just this image
it's any image we can do this with
okay so what's that's 400 that was 400
waves
and we have to think about there's a
very clever way of actually adding those
waves together and this is what furry
analysis tells us furry analysis tells
us how much of the first wave you need
how much of the second wave third fourth
and how you change the phase of those
waves the relationship how you change
the frequencies
i'm really something ironic about you
doing mister happy there is oh i'm quite
happy at the moment look i moved office
i've got a wonderful view out wonderful
new view it's not the car park so i'm
sure it's the greenery that's um made me
made me the question is then how do you
work out what those spatial correlations
are how do you work out whether these
points are related well one way of doing
it
is that you look at the waves that make
up the image
and if those waves um
by breaking down the image into those
waves you can you have a quantitative
measure of just you know basically you
can compare the furrier components of
two images and from that you can work
out what the degree of randomness
effectively is so what we would do
is we'd look at for example the
amplitudes of the waves that we need to
recreate the image and the frequency
right and if it's entirely random we
don't see any particular peaks
however if it's not random which means
that there's a particular correlation
length there's a particular um
feature spacing which is more common
than the rest
then what we'll see not drawn to scale
is a peak of some description so if you
did a fourier analysis or a wave
amplification as i call it yeah that's
good of say
the mona lisa yeah
you'd have a very distinct looking you
would indeed you'd have a very distinct
looking thing and it's not just okay
this is a very simple image let's let's
let's work in another image and let's do
say
nine for your components very indistinct
let's go for uh
let's go for 36 components
start to look familiar
looks like elvis looks like elvis okay
let's go for 64.
better put you out of your misery and
let's go for say 144 components oh yeah
right someone as handsome as opposed uh
indeed indeed so let's do a few more go
for a thousand thousand a thousand
not a particularly well written bit of
code for those of you who would be picky
about the code okay i'm not a
well-written bit of code there we go and
you can still see if we were added in
more components you get more but you can
see it it
works
you've ended on a high so
it didn't
indeed we could we could end it there
what this technique of fourier analysis
tells you is that actually to make a
wavelength looks like that you have to
add a whole bunch of sine waves together
and in the middle here they all
interfere with each other in a
constructive way so they all add up
together